- 2016 just started,
but there's already a
brand-new viral trend.
It's called CD glasses flipping.
Do you know about it?
- No.
(funky techno music)
- So what you do,
you put them on like this.
^- [Tyler] And then like?
- And then go like that.
And then like that.
- Oh, I got this.
- This is a thing?
- Oh, yeah!
(yelling)
- He's lying. He's making that up.
We didn't do that, we didn't do that!
- Just like this?
- Yeah.
Then just tilt your
head back a little bit.
There you go, yeah!
And then forward
(mic cracks)
- How'd that go?
- I got this.
(chuckles) I don't got it.
- Hey!
- And then forward.
- Boom!
(groans)
- What, what!?
- Oh, wow.
Flip your head back.
(squeals)
- I broke it!
- [Christian] You did so great!
- [Neil] Oh my God.
- And they open.
- [Zach] Yes!
- [Maggie] What!?
- I see you, peek-a-boo!
- And back!
- Maybe.
- [Christian] Oh no, he
should be first, all right.
(digital beep)
- What do you think about this as a trend?
- I think it's awful.
- Right, well thanks for your time.
We appreciate it.
- [Neil] This is what I've
been waiting for all night.
This is the reason why I came
to the People's Choice Awards,
so I could do this.
- Muah!